i am amazed at how few people have a
belief system what do they actually
believe in
um
i
and and yeah it's okay to offend you
guys
90 of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do
and
you know i even when i come to an event
like this say why am i here why would i
even bother to take an hour of my
valuable time
no it's true i i have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if i can convert
one of you
there's probably 400 500 people here if
i can convert one of you to follow your
belief and have the guts to follow your
belief
i'll have
i'll think of the hour as well spent
but
so i always say what am i trying to do
and why i don't speak because somebody
you know will write nice things about it
i always sort of have a purpose but i
have a belief system
and
most people even successful companies
and have big beef with fortune 500 ceos
i can talk about
there's very little leadership there
don't have an internal compass of what
they believe in
it's what do others expect
you know when i graduated
i went into entrepreneurship
nobody went into entrepreneurship out of
the business school and people said why
wouldn't you work
for goldman or mckinsey and i said why
would you
like i couldn't fathom why you would
want to
do that job
right
i still can't by the way
for those of you going to those places
i'm sure there's plenty i'm probably not
the right person to talk to you
i frankly don't even care to talk to you
all of you others
i i think there's something wrong with
anybody who fundamentally wants to go
work for one of the consultants or the
investment banks today in this part
they don't understand how the world is
going to work in the future
but my point again is have a belief
system follow that compass
and i'm overstating it a bit so
there may be some hope for those of you
going there
but
it's only a little bit of an
exaggeration
let me go back to this issue of fortune
500 ceos
i've talked to many over the years
if a new york times writer writes an
article
they want to change their strategy they
want to respond
how silly is that that some english
major who's never had a business job can
determine the strategy of a fortune 500
company
why because they care about what's
written not what their belief system is
do you know what elon musk would say to
that writer go get a real job
right
what jeff bezos would say that's
leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do
not you're fitting in to do career
enhancement
or
making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your friends or to your
boss or to
shareholders and frankly
you look at all the companies that are
languishing in the valley the older
companies
they generally don't have a belief
system they're generally trying to meet
some quarterly target without saying
here's how we will be different and
here's how we'll do it
apple did languish for 10 15 years and
then steve jobs came in with a point of
view and created the most valuable
company in the world he did irrational
things if you go back to january of 2007
january 1 everybody was saying nobody
wants a phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs 6.99 i
can go on with the litany
those were all english majors writing
articles i have this beef against
english majors
not all english majors are bad but the
majority of them at stanford are
undirected and don't have a goal or a
purpose
sorry
and that's not to say among them there
isn't 20 that are really good they just
didn't get the right guidance and ended
up in the wrong place
i like purposeful education anyway sorry
back to you i think about it think what
what can i do that you can't do
now i get to work in a job that i love
but i've always worked in the job i
loved i loved it when i i loved it just
as much when i well you know when it was
a big deal if i made a thousand bucks
and
i urge you to work in jobs you love i
mean i think you're out of your mind
if you take keep taking jobs that you
don't like because you think it'll look
good on your resume i was with a fellow
at harvard the other day who was taking
me over to talk and he was 28 and he was
telling me all about what he'd done in
life and which was terrific and and then
i said what are you going to do next and
he said well
he said after i get out my
my uh mba says i think maybe i've got to
work for a management consulting firm
because
it'll look good on my resume
and i said wait a second 28 you've been
doing all these things i mean you've got
a resume that's 10 times as good as
anybody i've ever seen it already i said
you take another job you don't like just
for i said isn't that a little like
saving up sex for your old age you know
i mean
there comes a time when you ought to
just start doing what you know yeah here
we go
so
i i think i got the point across to him
uh
but i you ought to take a job when you
get out of here take a job you love
don't take a job that you know you think
is gonna look good on your resume take a
job you love it you may change it later
on but you'll jump out of bed in the
morning i mean when i got out when i got
out of columbia the first thing i tried
to go to work for graham immediately i
offered to go to work for him for
nothing he said i was overpriced but
but i had but i kept pestering him i
went out to alma and i sold securities
for three years and i kept writing him
and giving him ideas and doing all these
things finally i went to work for a
couple years
and
it was a great experience but i always
really worked in a job i worked in a job
that that i would
that i've you know loved doing and you
should really take a job that if you
were independently wealthy you would
take that's that's the job to take
because that's the one that you're going
to have great fun in you'll learn
something you'll be excited about it
and you can't miss you may go and do
something else later on but but
you'll get way more out of it and i
don't care what the starting salary is
or anything of the sort uh
i don't know how i got off on that but i
uh there i am uh
so i i do think that
that
if you think you're going to be a lot
happier if you've got 2x instead of x
you're probably making a mistake i mean
it uh
yeah
you ought to you ought to find something
you like
that's that works with that and it and
you'll get in trouble if if you think
that making 10x or 20x is the answer to
everything in life because then you will
do things like borrow money when you
shouldn't or or maybe you cut corners on
on things that your employer wants you
to cut corners on or it just doesn't
make any sense you won't like it when
you look back on it
well i think this is the inno score card
is is uh it's not a static it's not a
static kind of
template if you will basically like when
i when i met buffett for lunch with my
friend guys pierre he said to us that
would you rather be the greatest lover
in the world
but known as the worst
or the worst lover in the world but
known as the greatest
and he said that if you know how to
answer that question you've got it made
okay
so the inner scorecard for all of us is
very straightforward we always know what
the internal correct answer is we know
that we have a conscious and we know
that it's just that it's very tempting
to live life with an outer school card
which is if people think i'm the
greatest lover
well let them think that that's awesome
and that would be an outer scorecard way
of living life
and
so
all you have to do is that when you
encounter distortions
between the inner scorecard and the
outer scorecard
focus on the inner scorecard and for
each
different type of
you know
activity or conclusion or whatever you
come to about something
your inner scorecard is really what
should guide you
so for example
if my fund is up 30 next year
you know everyone would be saying oh
that was awesome
but what i have to do internally is ask
myself well
what was the risk i took
was it risk-free
was it truly
a great return relative to
uh and was it the best opportunity cost
of the way i could put the money these
are questions i can answer better
because i have underlying data
a lot richer underlying data and so the
easiest person to fool
is to fool yourself
and you really have to make sure you're
not fooling yourself so an inner score
card is a really important it's it's a
really huge advantage in life
to live live your life with an inner
score card what will happen is
that if you live with it in a scorecard
you will become more trustable
you'll become more trustworthy
and
if a lot of humans are willing to put a
lot of trust in you that's a starting
point that's going to give you a huge
edge in life
[Music]
you